at this altitude I can for my books I've
loved on the Tim Ferriss show is
exclusively brought to you by audible
there couldn't be a better sponsor for
this series my dear listeners and
readers I have used audible for so many
years as long as I can remember I love
it
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet I listen when
I'm taking walks I listen while I'm
cooking I listen whenever I can and if
you're looking for a place to start
I can recommend three of my favorites
the first is the Tao of Seneca by Seneca
if you want to hear my favorite letters
of all time touches on stoic philosophy
calmness under duress etc the next is
the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman GA IMA
n one of my favorites even if you're a
nonfiction purist this is the fiction
book that you need to listen to neo also
has perhaps the most calming voice of
all time in 3rd Gregg McEwan's
essentialism subtitle the disciplined
pursuit of less this is one of my
favorite books of the past few years
combines very well with the 8020
principle but more inaudible every month
audible members get one credit for any
audiobook on the site plus a choice of
multiple audible originals from a
rotating selection they also get access
to daily news digests from the likes of
the New York Times Wall Street Journal
and The Washington Post as well as
guided meditation programs and here are
some other amazing audible features and
I use a bunch of these you can download
titles and listen offline anytime
anywhere I use this feature even when I
could get access I'll put my phone on
say airplane mode because I want to get
bothered with notifications and I'm
taking a walk to clear my head and you
can listen to you titles offline in a
case like that or on a plane or whatever
obviously I'm not flying much these days
the app is free and can be installed on
all smartphones and
tablets you can listen across devices
without losing your spot and whisper
sync is another feature I use quite a
lot
I love reading my kindle in bed for
instance then picking up at the same
exact spot where I left off when I go
walking and listening the next day
Kindle and audio versions can be synched
up automatically it's just amazing and
if you can't decide what the listen to
don't sweat it you don't have to rush
you can keep your credits for up to a
year and use them for instance to binge
on a whole series if you like audible
offers just about everything podcasts
guided wellness programs theatrical
performances a list comedy and audible
originals you won't find anywhere else
and right now audible is offering you
guys that's Tim Ferriss show listeners a
free audiobook with a 30-day trial
membership and again my list if you want
to check them out the Tao of Seneca the
graveyard book essentialism those are
just three there's so many good ones out
there just go to audible.com slash tim
and browse the unmatched selection of
audio programs then download your free
title and start listening it's that easy
let's check it out go to audible.com
slash tim or text tim t IM - 500 500 to
get started today check it out
audible.com slash tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is usually my job to sit down with
world-class performers of all different
types startup founders investors chess
champions Olympic athletes you name it
to tease out the habits that you can
apply in your own lives this episode
however is an experiment and part of a
short-form series that I'm doing simply
called books I've loved I've invited
some amazing past guests close friends
and new faces to share their favorite
books describe their favorite books the
books that have influenced them changed
them transform them for the better and I
hope you pick up one or two new mentors
in the form of books from this new
series and apply the lessons in your own
life I had a lot of fun putting this
together inviting these people to
participate and have learned so so much
myself I hope that is also the case for
you please enjoy hi i'm cindy eckert and
i'm an entrepreneur who's built and sold
to successful pharmaceutical companies
i'm perhaps best known for my last
sprout pharmaceuticals that broke
through with the first and only
fda-approved pill for women's low libido
that's right I said low libido I sold
that business for a cool billion dollars
upfront and went on to put my money
where my mouth is so today I invest in
other disruptive female founders and
disruptive technologies and health
inside of my pinky bader that's right I
said pink at a little pink pill I love
pink but perhaps the biggest twist and
turn of my unconventional story is that
the company that I sold for a billion
dollars well I got it back for nothing
last year so how does that happen I
fought to get it back because the
company I sold it to never launched it
and that was not gonna happen on my
watch when we'd won one for women guys
have had 26 options I thought was about
damn time that women had one of their
own so we went after getting it back and
I'm delighted to say we're successful in
doing that and that the shareholders
kept the billion so now I'm on a mission
to launch a D as well
as many other firsts for women but I
should say of all the career highlights
maybe one of the top ones is being
interviewed by Tim Ferriss so when he
called and said alright Cindy what are
books you love I got to thinking the
first one that came to mind no brainer
for me Purple Cow by Seth Godin it is
such a good book so what's it about well
it's right there in the title for you
there are tons of brown cows out there
but it takes a purple cow to grab your
attention and his book is a marketing
book it talks about the model of
marketing it talked about how you know
the old model of marketing was the huge
companies with giant budgets who got to
have the Superbowl ads like they were
gonna win they were even went through
money and exposure and how that model
really has been disrupted and that we
had these you know remarkable brands
that attract remarkable to them that's
the purple cow philosophy so as I was
reading it in the context of marketing
it really struck me but isn't that a
philosophy with which to build a
business so I said I've built two
companies dial back to my first one
slate and really purple cow for a
philosophical standpoint the standing
out in a sea of sameness was so
fundamental to the core of what I was
trying to accomplish that literally if
you go back and look at email signatures
for people instead of saying best
regards Cheers whatever your sign-off is
many times when you look at my original
team that worked with me the sign off is
Moo Moo because I talked about it so
damn much the purple cow philosophy how
are we going to go out there and stand
out in a sea of sameness I've been in
big environments I was in those big
environments and I was successful but
totally uninspired I was in environments
that believed the only way to be
successful was to homogenize was to make
us all brown cows and we had to follow
the certain way
and really the hunch was when I started
sleep wait a minute there are other
people out there just like me there in
those environments they are successful
because of their own drive and
determination but they're not inspired
and you're actually not tapping into
this purple cow aspect of them that will
make you remarkable and so I hire it
against it I fire it against it I
incentivized we dressed up at Halloween
so my employees came in dressed as
purple cows I mean we really got it
because if you come into my office let's
just say hiring for example by the time
somebody gets to my desk
and has been vetted by my team they're
abundantly qualified to have the job
what I was looking for was purple cow
characteristics how did they stand out
from everyone else how are they
remarkable in a way that was going to
attract remarkable to them and and so
those were really what I was torturing
purple cow I believe is an outstanding
read for everybody not only if you're in
marketing and you want to understand how
the old rules don't apply anymore but
really philosophically for how you
embrace how you show up in this world
you know I show up in pink hot pink to
be exact and that was born out of
irreverence if I'm being quite honest
because people would pat me on the
shoulder when I was trying to get the
first ever pink pill approved for women
and the pink became a symbol if you will
of what I was fighting for I like pink
by the way I've always liked pink I look
back at childhood photos I'm almost
always in pink and that was the signal
to me that you have to show up really
loudly exactly as you are and I will say
though despite my best efforts Seth
Godin has still not released the pink
cow but I'm counting on that coming out
maybe 2020 South I don't know let's
let's look at it so love Purple Cow
highly recommend it let's talk about
another book that I love and Tim and I
haven't talked about it before but I bet
you this one is on his list too
and that is a curious mind by Brian
Grazer and if you don't know his name I
gotta tell you you definitely know his
award-winning movies I mean he's worked
with Tom Hanks on so many projects he's
partnered with Ron Howard these you know
little names and he's had all of these
40 plus I think Academy Awards he has
one and a curious mind is about this one
thing that has the ability to connect us
all and that is curiosity and like I
cannot agree more mmm enthusiastically
with that concept because if I think
about all of the successful people I've
had the privilege to meet over the years
I do feel like that's it they are wired
with curiosity to the core and in his
book Brian in a curious mind he talks
about really techniques in which you can
cultivate your own curiosity so he gives
very practical tips but one of his is
that he schedules a curiosity
conversation with somebody he doesn't
know who's outside of his own discipline
and he really sits down as a discipline
on his calendar
he puts aside time really for a
curiosity endeavor because he knows that
when he sits down and learns her
mother's he can apply that to what he's
doing and I think that's it right the
more hallmark of the best and most
successful entrepreneurs is that they
are almost insatiably curious it allows
them the ability to not only be
constantly learning and applying those
new lessons but open-minded enough to be
able to do that because I gotta tell you
it is not a straight line to success and
if you're not open-minded enough to
listen and you know make the turn
slightly to the left or slightly to the
right you'll never get there it it
inspired in me a lot of thinking about
you know why did I become an
entrepreneur and what laid the
foundation for that maybe very early on
in a way that I wasn't even
conscious of and what I think in that
regard is my parents cultivated my
curiosity and I have two big brothers we
laugh about this we shared this story
and this is when we were little and we
would go to our parents for help with
homework you know you want the leg up
you want the quick fix and the answer
regardless of the question it could have
been a math question it could be an
English question when we ask them the
question they would reply with the same
four words and they were what do you
think it was infuriating by the way at
the time in which she just wanted the
assist from your parents make it a
little bit simpler but really what they
were doing I give them a lot of credit
for this I think sometimes they
genuinely were just tired but I think at
the core of it the what do you think was
cultivating curiosity and that curiosity
showed up in this way so if they weren't
gonna give me the answer I was gonna
have to be willing to go and ask others
and get their point of view I was gonna
have to develop my own point of view and
independent thinking along the way and
all of that
cultivation of you know the approach of
constant learning the approach of
forming your own opinions the approach
of realizing that it's not going to be
handed to you by someone all-knowing
above who's going to pass down the
perfect answer really is foundationally
so very helpful to me as I've gone
through my career as I have built
businesses from scratch as I have sold
them the curiosity is what has kept me
showing up for more so if I'm thinking
about you know two books that I truly
love and I couldn't recommend them more
highly it would be Purple Cow from Seth
Godin for all of you listening I hope
you always show up as the purple cow and
separate yourselves in the sea of
sameness let's be honest there's a lot
out there today we get a lot of messages
coming at us fast and furious you've got
a standout and
really the simplest way to stand out is
to be authentically you that separates
you from everybody else
and the curious a curious mind by Brian
Grazer the curiosity factor is the
difference between good and great it
will be I don't know the recipe in my
mind for the most successful and frankly
fulfilling life do yourself a favor and
have a curiosity conversation put it on
your calendar if that's how you roll or
just open up your mind to the thought
that mentors don't come just looking up
mentors come to your left and your right
every single day and you should be
challenging yourself to learn from them
thanks so much for having me Tim this is
Alexis Ohanian best-selling author
co-founder of initialised capital an
early-stage venture firm and an read it
but today I'm here to talk about books I
love and shout out to my buddy Tim
Ferriss for this really great idea and
for inviting me to talk about it I have
two books that I want to talk about
today and one made a pretty big impact
on my life at a pivotal moment the other
I just recently read and have been
obsessed obsessed with first Masters of
doom by David Kushner now this book is
about the founding story of Ede software
and if you were like me grew up playing
video games this company invented the
genre of the first-person shooter with a
game called Wolfenstein 3d and it was
pretty special I played a lot of video
games as a kid and most of them were
made by it but this book came into my
life at a really important time because
I was I was a student at the University
of Virginia I was actually on my way to
becoming a lawyer
I had majored in history and business
and like any good history major was
taking the LSAT when I walked out
I walked out of that LSAT and I walked
into a Waffle House because I was hungry
that was it I just really wanted a
waffle and eating that waffle I realized
if I chose breakfast over the LSAT I
probably should not be a lawyer so I
went home and I started thinking about
what I was going to do with my life
since it obviously wasn't the law and
this book masters adom had recently been
recommended to me and I dug in and found
myself hearing the story of John Carmack
and John Romero the two founders of it
and how they built this business eating
pizza staying up late writing code and
doing something they genuinely loved and
that somehow managed to be a video game
Empire really shaped an entire industry
to this day I mean if you're playing
Call of Duty or battlefield you're
playing a game that is a sort of
relative a great-great grandson or
daughter of Wolfenstein 3d which was the
really the first first-person shooter
and so here were some random dudes not
unlike me and my co-founder who built
something that changed an entire
industry and that really crystallized
for me what some really passionate
founders who could write some code could
do to change things and this gave me the
confidence to say you know what they can
do this we can definitely do this and I
convinced my roommate to start a company
with me that company was called my
mobile menu mmm for short it would let
people skip lines by ordering food from
their phones but it was like 2004-2005
so there were no smartphones it was a
terrible idea it was ahead of its time
and thankfully we got we got convinced
to not pursue that idea by Y Combinator
and instead started another company
called reddit so so without a doubt read
it would not exist if it weren't for
masters of doom well and also Waffle
House so thank you awful house but I can
think of no better place to read masters
of doom than your local Waffle House so
there you go it changed my life in so
many ways and at the time felt so
insignificant it was just the right book
at the right time and I've gotten the
chance to actually thank the author
David for writing it because really read
it would not exist if not for masters of
doom so there you go it's a great read
highly recommended and especially if
you're a gamer because these are the
news of the forefathers of everything
that we really know in gaming today the
other book that I want to recommend is
one that I actually read pretty recently
for the first time or if I'm being
really honest with you I listened to the
audiobook I still don't really know how
you're supposed to describe that if you
do you read an audiobook or do you
listen to an audio book I mean I guess
you really listen to it it just feels I
don't know it feels less impressive when
you're like uh listen to this great
audiobook rather than read anyway
consume your books however you like
the second is why we sleep the new
science of sleep and dreams by Matthew
Walker and this was something that I'd
had recommended to me so many times and
it was it was funny cuz I was in a new
dad at the time so my daughter Olympia
was born on September 1st 2017 and this
book must have come out around then or
some point that year because I was
getting it recommended to me all the
time while I was unable to sleep because
I had a newborn and I thought this is
some delightful trolling and you know
like a lot of things I kind of put it
off and put it off and then finally was
a car at our time and check this thing
out everyone keeps recommending it to me
and so I prioritized it in the audible
account gave it a listen and have not
been able to stop thinking about it
because really thanks to technology we
now can really start to understand this
really important process that all living
creatures need but we we've never really
been able to understand we've we've been
able to do so much research on so many
other things that we humans need to
survive except for sleep but thanks to
improvements in all kinds of technology
brain scanning and whatnot and just
years and years of research by
neuroscientists like Matthew Walker
we're now starting to understand just
what sleep does and why it is so damn
valuable and then also how we can better
sort of orchestrate it in our lives and
and I've been someone who is very
fortunate as sort of genetically blessed
and and thanks to my mom I think I've
never had any trouble sleeping ever I
can sleep knock on wood
you know anywhere right now in the
middle this podcast you said Alexis I
really need you to go go to sleep I
could I could go and curl up in a nice
chair or ideally in a nice bed but I
could curl than a nice chair and be out
in probably ten minutes and and most
nights I would get probably six six
hours of sleep was my goal if I got six
I thought alright great let's do it but
I never really understood why any of
that was important and in fact during my
20s and especially founding reddit I'd
sleep even less and I almost I think I
relished it at the time because in some
weird perverse way I thought that was
like showing that I was more serious
than anyone else about my startup which
was dumb
in hindsight and really thanks to this
book I've started to understand just how
damaging that was and and lack of sleep
is and just how important it is
especially if you're trying to do next
level type work how important it is to
get rest and recovery and it may seem
obvious to you it definitely didn't to
me but the recovery and rest is is as or
more important than the work one
actually does any you know you don't
need to look much further than even
professional athletes who have the most
objectively hard and demanding sort of
industries because there are winners and
losers every day and it's all ranked and
you know if a fairly level playing field
and so we make up the wins and losses in
business and the the way we keep score
but in sport it's it's it's very
objective and very clear and so it
should have been no surprise to me that
sleep mattered because every one of the
greatest athletes talked about the time
that they spend recovering as being as
important or more so than the time they
spend at work and so it was a humbling
thing to be listening to this and
realizing just how dumb I had been for
15 or so years of my life where I was
really almost always sacrificing sleep
in the name of whatever else it was I
was trying to do and I you know I'm a
new parent now and thankfully my
daughter is sleeping quite regularly
because you learn from the book it's
actually really important in child brain
development and I'm really trying to
prioritize it now I am really going out
of my way to get eight to nine hours of
sleep every day almost no matter what
and I have found so many subtle
improvements in my own life that have
come from it and I hope the long-term
ones will add up to I won't know you
have to check back in within a few years
but the research really is starting to
help us understand just how important
that time is and just how dangerous it
is for us to be living our lives on not
enough sleep the author talks about
everything from drowsy driving to the
health impacts like the actual internal
damage you're causing in the long-term
with consistent sleep deprivation and so
you know these are two very different
books they are I think
indirectly gonna help you build
billion-dollar companies which is the
that's the business I'm in now is to
help founders build companies that are
even bigger and better than reddit
and I love that job and so as an
investor and initialized I get to give
occasional pearls of wisdom to founders
and sometimes they come in the form of
books and these are two books that I
found myself for recommending quite a
bit over the years and so hopefully
they'll be helpful for you too and
either way whether you like them or you
hate them let me know but those are
masters of doom and why we sleep so
thanks for listening it's been a
pleasure I'll see you on the other hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday the event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include a favorite articles
that I have read and that I've shared
with my close friends for instance and
it's very short it's just a little tiny
bite of goodness before you head off for
the weekend so if you want to receive
that check it out just go to 4-hour
workweek dot-com that's 4-hour workweek
calm I'll spell them out and just drop
in your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up I hope you
enjoy
you
you
you
you